on behalf of all Kenyans let me
congratulate you on winning the global
teacher prize for this year you are a
shining example of what the human spirit
can achieve not just for Kenya
not just for Africa but for the world
Peter you chose to teach in a remote
part of Kenya
Kiriko mixed a secondary school and you
chose to transform lives in such
situations a choice that I'm sure was
difficult you give me faith that
Africa's best days are ahead of us
and your story will light the way for
all future generations Your Highness
Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid Al Maktoum
your support for the teaching profession
and your continued patronage of the
global teacher prize is changing the
lives of many teachers and children
around the world I also recognize the
contribution of mr. Sonny [ __ ] the
Varkey foundation and all those who have
made this celebration possible your
commitment to education throughout the
world is commendable to all our
finalists and to each and every
dedicated teacher around the world let
me say
the future of our planet the future of
our young people is in your hands and we
will support you in achieving this noble
goal congratulations to all and
especially to you Peter
thank you